à leur retour de voyage mais va erinyes
ont une mauvaise surprise
leurs voisins s'est construit une
galerie dont la structure fraude la
limite de leur terrain pourtant selon le
règlement municipal zonage cette galerie
de retrouver à au moins un mètre de la
ligne de séparation et leurs voisins
obtenu une dérogation mineure de la
municipalité résolution du conseil de
ville la construction de la galerie à
cet endroit a été autorisé comment le
conseil at il dit accepter cette
dérogation sans même consulter les
premiers concernés c'est que la loi
n'oblige la ville qui a publié un avis
public
traditionnellement ces avis sont publiés
dans un journal local
mais la loi permet maintenant aux
municipalités de ne publier ses avis que
sur leur site internet
or maeva et rémy n'ont jamais pensé à ça
s'il avait lu la vie il aurait pu se
présenter à la réunion du conseil pour
faire valoir leurs points temps
le fin mot de l'histoire garder un oeil
sur les avis publics si vous voulez
garder votre belle vue et